we now live in a world where an old
tweet can cost you your TV show movie
franchise or a list journalism gig a
world where senators demand social media
platforms police their content a world
where the courts have time and time
again upheld broad protection of our
First Amendment rights for expression
has never been more abundant more
complicated or more embattled to get a
handle on how to make sense of all of
this reason turned to one of the legal
professions sharpest First Amendment
practitioners ken white is the
proprietor of the great legal blog Pope
at and he's also the host of the make no
law podcast a former and repentant
federal prosecutor White's day job as
being a criminal defense attorney at the
Los Angeles law firm of brown white and
Osborn in a wide-ranging discussion
I talked with white about the dismissal
of director James Gunn from the
guardians of the galaxy film series what
limits should be put on employees speech
inside and outside the workplace and how
he came to his nuanced libertarian views
about law and society we kick off the
conversation by getting his views on
Brett Kavanaugh Trump's nominee for the
Supreme Court let's talk about Brett
Kavanaugh he has been getting mostly
kind of tongue baths from the
right-of-center he was on the
Federalists list that or the big list
that was put together by the Federalist
Society and the Heritage Society and
combined by one of trumps advisors Brett
Kavanaugh is he good or bad for the
libertarians I don't think he's
consistent on that point so speaking as
a criminal defense attorney I don't like
how he deals with criminal defense
issues search and seizure
the fifth amendment the sixth amendment
those types of things he seems to be a
fairly typical mainstream conservative
on though someone in the mode of a
Rehnquist or an Alito or someone in that
and when by that you mean he is you know
he's gonna if something when the coin
toss comes like should we proceed or not
he's always gonna flip it to to law
enforcement right he's going to give law
enforcement the benefit of the doubt
he's going to continue to engage
Justice Scalia's fantasy though there's
this new professionalism amongst police
and therefore we can give them more
deference he's going to continue the
general trend of cutting back and
narrowing the criminal defendants rights
established during the Warren Court long
time ago now so you clearly grew up
watching Dirty Harry movies and whenever
you know the week chind liberal just a
lawyer would get his guy off because
Dirty Harry hadn't like fully secured
the crimes right we're like I want to be
that guy but everybody else in America
and certainly Brett Kavanaugh is like no
Dirty Harry is right everyone else wants
to be Clint Eastwood saying oh I'm
broken up you want to be the effete
three-piece suit wearing feather bang
blown mustache guy okay now you do it
and commit some more crime it's a living
you know it's because everyone turns
into that guy once it's their person who
is getting arrested or charged and you
don't see that so you hear a lot of
people talking about how badly scooter
libby was treated by rican justice
system which thankfully pardoned him
well exactly you you see him you see all
the talk about how terribly the criminal
justice system is treating various
people in the trump orbit Oh Joe Arpaio
yeah what a raw deal right exactly so
everyone loves the rights wants someone
they like a respect is getting charged
what but to go to this question a little
bit off kilter because it's more about
criminology but Scalia when he was
talking about things like you know the
new professionalism which even which
even cropped up in arguments he was
making about how like you got to trust
police dogs release dogs who there is
like no scientifically validated
evidence that police dogs are you know
good at anything other than [ __ ] on
people's long come on but these are not
just any [ __ ] off the street this is
the new professional but this is he was
saying like you know what if they if
goddamnit if you'd have the cop running
that guy you know that dog says he's a
goddamn good cop you know you know then
he'd think the dog knows what he's doing
type of thing but it is true over the
past 25 years we've seen massive
decreases in crime in a lot of ways and
I even talked to people like our former
colleague Radley Balko who will grant
that we're we are we witness
more police brutality and overreach but
that's mostly a function of having
technology that captures it it's
probably true that cops are less bad
than they used to be or it you know
that's my contention is that true I
don't know whether it's true or not but
I'm skeptical about applying that as a
reason to narrow our Fourth and Fifth
Amendment rights and other rights you
know so the way Scalia used that
particular idea was to reduce the
remedies we have when officers do
violate our rights so it's no longer a
question of should we trust that nothing
bad happened it's question of when
something bad happens when the officer
breaks the law what should the remedy be
and the connection there between cops
are not as bad now so there shouldn't be
a remedy is not clear to me the
interesting thing about Scalia was that
he was decent on the Fourth Amendment
when it came to does it apply to this
new technology does it apply to this new
situation are you just gonna get around
it
where he was bad was on remedies what on
what do you do now that we've
established it so he was he was actually
good on saying like well you know the
founders didn't envision cellphone
towers or heat thermo you know things
you could look through to see whether or
not pot plants were being grown with oh
you know heavy uses of electricity he'd
be like no that's us that's a search and
you need a warrant for it but then once
the cops go in there and start beating
the [ __ ] out of people he's like hey
what do you expect well yeah one once
he's gonna say they need a warrant until
they come up with some warrant
exceptional we thought we heard someone
yelling help and then he's gonna so I
think that does Cavanaugh in following
things like that is he is he indebted to
Scalia's jurisprudence or is he coming
at that from his own original point of
view Behrman there's a limited amount of
Fourth Amendment Fifth Amendment case
law from Cavanaugh he's in the DC
Circuit which is less likely than some
other circuits to have that sort of
thing so that's a lot of politicians
who's just trying to figure out are
these people human should they be tried
in a human court
and the FCC and Federal Elections
Commission and all those types of things
that's why there's a lot of First
Amendment stuff on right which I'm sure
we'll get to but in terms of the Fourth
Amendment stuff there's less he seems to
be a more typical sort of Rehnquist
Alito that type of style of conservative
not quite so robust in protection of the
Fourth Amendment as Scalia was but it's
a little early to tell either B to say
the consensus is and I think it's fair
is that he should not be regarded as
someone who reliably will hold the line
on Fourth Amendment rights what about
free speech or the speech issues that
have come up and First Amendment issues
with him where where is he coming down
on that in your mind I think he is does
a pretty good job I did a fairly deep
dive on it and looked read through
because this is my life all of the cases
where he wrote an opinion or even joined
one about the First Amendment and what I
saw as a few things first of all he
would be very supportive of what people
are sort of trash-talking as weaponizing
the First Amendment and what they mean
by that is applying the First Amendment
to regulatory and economic type laws
that it always hasn't been robustly
applied to so probably the example that
makes people the maddest is net
neutrality and he said several times in
FCC cases that look a networks decision
about what to air as part of their First
Amendment rights and you can't order
them to air things or not air things to
carry stuff on cable or not unless you
can meet the standards that the First
Amendment applies so he's saying you
know you need to show they have some
sort of disruptive market power in that
market and people are very angry at that
they could have put can you put like
some flesh on that that shirt Apple so
what would that mean in a particular
case well it might mean forcing cable
companies to carry programs produced by
competitors so a lot of people say
that's like net neutral
it's you know the cable should be open
to everyone everyone should carry all
the programs and someone like Cavanaugh
says while I understand the policy
reasons you want that but in terms of
First Amendment rights the company how
much you hate them charger cable any of
these they should be able to decide what
shows they want to put on if they don't
want competitor shows they shouldn't
have to run them unless you can meet the
very high standards that the First
Amendment imposes what would that be
like I mean because there are the things
I mean in cable operations or in cable
law there are must carry laws so you
cable the cable system has to carry in
this I it took me years to figure out
that I wasn't misunderstanding it but
that any cable operator has to carry
must carry all of the stations that are
available to its customers over-the-air
right which makes no sense at all
because it's like I could just buy it
antenna and watch these things but then
they're gonna clog up or limit your
chance your choices on cable because you
got to put in the three ABC affiliates
and the NBC people and all of that sure
and the policy reasons for those is that
there's not enough competition and the
cable market and people will have access
to these things as easily unless we
force the cable companies to carry them
the First Amendment response to that is
that's fine as a policy but you don't
get to force companies to do that unless
you can meet basically strict scrutiny
and what Kavanaugh has been saying is
not that you should never be able to
force that but that the FCC should have
to make a market dominance showing show
that these cable companies have
basically manipulated dominated local
market so there is a reason that people
can't get those channels from another
source so and the FCC doesn't want to do
that the FCC and its supporters
basically would like to have the
must-carry law as apply without any sort
of necessity of showing that some sort
of market defect requires and and
especially once I mean it's been
repealed but under
kind of open Internet order where it
moves treating the Internet as a public
utility then it becomes it's almost like
a food court in the Senate where now
you've got to have McDonald's and Burger
King and then you've got to have unum
Skyline Chili because the guy from Ohio
wants that and you know whatever small
local franchise that everything has to
be fit because you know that's we're
representing everybody right and so
questioning net neutrality the idea that
carriers should have to carry everything
at the same speed I think is one of the
biggest modern heresies to anyone who
talks or operates on the internet it's
it's you know the untouchable subject
but I mean to people like Kavanaugh it's
simply why do we pretend that the First
Amendment doesn't apply here when it
does why should the government be able
to tell cable operators what to carry
and how to carry it without meeting the
same test that we would have to do if we
were telling them you know you can't
show that political show so he's in that
sense very robustly in favor of
aggressive application of the First
Amendment he also seems to be strong on
the issues that we First Amendment gurus
care about the most about a very careful
application of defamation law to protect
opinion he's clearly concerned about how
frivolous litigation chills speech he
has struck down laws that limit
demonstrations in national parks and
things like that it's that weight so he
struck down the laws that limited the
ability of people to demonstrate or he
limited the demonstrations sorry he he
struck down a law that required
pre-registration for demonstrations in
certain national spaces saying it put
too much of a burden on speech and that
is I mean I guess that's part of the
First Amendment that seems to get less
attention but the idea of free assembly
right absolutely
assembly freedom of petition he's looked
at those things and he comes out looking
pretty good again from a robust kind of
civil libertarian perspective sure there
are a few places where traditional
conservative judicial philosophy
intersects with the First Amendment in a
way that winds up practically speaking
limiting rights so for instance he
fairly strongly as two most conservative
judges limits the right to sue the
government for things under for instance
section 1983 which allows you to sue
state actors for acting under the color
of state law violating your rights so he
like many conservative judges places
fairly high barriers to bringing in
those suits and when the issue is a
First Amendment right that has the
effect of limiting First Amendment
rights but it doesn't appear he's going
after it from a we should limit First
Amendment rights perspective it's more
from a more you know run-of-the-mill
conservative we should limit these
statutory rights to sue the government
in a broad sense does he have a or has
he articulated a judicial philosophy
that you know is he an originalist is he
is he a textualist is he this is he that
you know I'm not sure that I see that
clearly coming through but I'm not as
much of an expert in those areas what I
do see about him is this having gone
through and pulled all his First
Amendment decisions he likes to write
his own opinions
he likes to concur and the result but
explaining his own rationale for getting
there he tends to like simpler cleaner
paths to get to things and that
sometimes winds up resembling textualism
or originalism but I think he's going to
be somebody who's going to on the
Supreme Court right a lot of dissents
and a lot of concurring opinions sort of
telling the majority you're doing it the
wrong way even if I agree with the
outcome you're getting there through
this stupid way so he is really gonna be
sitting by himself at the Supreme Court
lunch table I take it because he'll he's
gonna be showing how much smarter he is
than all of them you know I think the
people there have built up a pretty high
tolerance for that sort of thing that
was certainly something that Scalia did
and yes Julia had very close friends on
both sides of the political aisle on the
court do you worry about
to balance that he the way he shifts the
balance of redistributed on the Supreme
Court because you know he's one of nine
so you know it's one thing to be who he
is in isolation but then is is this
gonna lead to a major shift in the way
the Supreme Court starts talking about
stuff it's certainly going to lead to a
shift but I think you have to put it in
context part of the context is a general
conservative shift over the last 40
years right and has just come back to a
Rehnquist or even before rank low yeah
exactly the reaction to the war on court
so everything from Nixon thereafter
there's also been and I had the older I
get the the slightly less alarmed I get
because I see the recurring patterns of
people saying this conservative
president is going to change the court
forever and there are changes but it's
rarely as stark and extreme as people
predict so a lot of the things I'm
hearing now about Kavanagh I heard when
George Bush Senior George HW Bush was
pointing people to the court at the end
of the 80s beginning of the 90s so I
think there will be changes I think
there will be a rightward drift I don't
think it will be as stark as people
think and I think as a First Amendment
junkie I'm happy that in general the
rightward drift of the court has not
resulted in a narrowing of First
Amendment rights for the most part do
you think that is that because the right
you know conservatives and sometimes
libertarians it's because the right
believes fully in the First Amendment
whereas we know you know the left
they're all agents of Russia oddly even
though the president I guess is an agent
of Russia it gets very confusing very
quickly but the it's the First Amendment
is being protected better now because
it's conservatives and conservatives
have a unique love for the First
Amendment where is that kind of
horseshit that right-wingers are trying
to push it's I think it's primarily
horseshit I think that politically
speaking conservatives and liberals
alike primarily like protecting speech
they agree with
that's sort of a very fundamental human
thing people are more likely to find
excuses to protect speech they like and
more likely to think of excuses to
suppress speech they don't like and I
don't see either conservatives or
liberals of has having a monopoly on
that attitude I think that the court in
terms of judicial philosophy there has
been a broader more robust protection of
the First Amendment but that hasn't
wound up being particularly politically
liberal or conservative I mean if you
look at some of the biggest cases of
this millennium some of them are just
not really conservative in the way they
protect the First Amendment so you you
know you look at Snyder versus Phelps
the Westboro Baptist Church protesting a
Marines funeral and saying all these
terrible things I don't really see that
as a conservative value politically
conservative but it did protect the
right of Westboro Baptist Church to to
show up and right white people at a
funeral exactly you look at the flag
burning cases a little older strictly
protect speech but in a way that
conservatives have used as a political
wedge for a long it's served by the way
is do you know anybody who could develop
a drug we could put in the water supply
so we're never talking about burning
flags again like you have why is this
even an issue I would have taken it if I
had so well I think it's because it's a
wedge issue right it's a perfect way to
say we love the flag look ourselves wrap
ourselves in it those guys hate the flag
see this is where if I went to a anti
flag burning rally or maybe a pro flag
burning rally I'd be really worried
about wrapping myself in a flag you want
it to be a fireproof line yeah that's
right in this match this flag exactly so
what I'm saying is that a lot of the
cases have not been really liberal
conservative there's been a run of cases
that really agitated citizens united
terribly being the biggest one in your
mind was that settled properly and then
more to the point is there a way where
we would ever be able to get to a you
know a kind of disinterested
articulation of
why political speech of all speech
should be essentially unregulated so
those are two complicated questions I do
think that in terms of the laws at issue
in citizens united if they were about
anything else it would be a nine to zero
decision because the type of limitation
on pure or political speech there is
just so clearly in First Amendment
heritage not permitted in other context
but people have this very strong policy
feeling and I don't think it's an
unreasonable policy feeling that money
is corrupting the politics and I happen
to agree with that but I think that a
lot of things are corrupting and the
First Amendment places limitations on
how we deal with it you have that you
have this term a bunch of them you have
the the the Janus case where would they
expanded the recognition of the First
Amendment right recognition of public
unions so that you have this free rider
issue where public people can you know
take advantage of the unions but not
have to pay in this a in the case mark
Janice who was a state employee in
Illinois objected having I think it was
fifty dollars taken out of his paycheck
to pay for what the Union that
represented him said was pure collective
bargaining it wasn't it had nothing to
do with you know setting up playgrounds
for kids or political politicking for
lobbying and stuff like that and he said
hey I don't want to pay this and the
Supreme Court agreed with them saying
that they couldn't force him to write
and that was five four and again I think
if it had been about anything else other
than public unions it would have been
seven two or eight one or self and of
course that case a very similar case a
couple years before dealing with
California teacher deadlocked at 4-4
because Scalia had just shuffled off his
mortal coil exactly and this is just the
ultimate a similar one I think in terms
of the way politics distorts the way we
look at it is a case involving compelled
speech at California where California
required crisis pregnancy centers to put
out all sorts of disclaimers
you know this isn't a real clinic you
can go get an abortion over there and
we're not like what's it was that it's
it wasn't a real clinic because they did
not perform abortions right so they
could say they're a birth control clinic
but basically wrapped in the definition
of that was the idea now you got to be
able to perform an abortion right once
again I think it was a lot closer that
decision that would have been if it had
been about anything about abortion so I
think things like unions abortion and
money and politics tend to generate war
purely openly result oriented
jurisprudence and me people expected
more and that's from both sides I mean I
think if you look at the opinion in the
compelled speech California case the
lengths that Justice Thomas went through
to try to defend an old case that did
the opposite that that said that the
federal government could tell doctors
that they had to kind of try to persuade
women away from abortion the hoops he
had to jump through to make that sound
okay under roasty of President made it
seem very results-oriented you could
hardly blame people for thinking the
fixes in so tough legal areas tend to
distort First Amendment analysis do you
feel we're also going through a kind of
spasm of places where purely ideological
or you know strongly political actors
are kind of trying to get people fired
this I mean we're talking not long after
James Gunn the director of the guardians
of the galaxy franchise which has made
billions of dollars worldwide for Disney
right a couple of right-wingers dug up
old tweets that he had made he'd worked
for a company called Troma which
traffic's and really kind of you know
depending on your perspective you know
brutally funny nasty mean perverse
horror movies I mean it's it's it's a
kind of meta the horror movie genre that
would make you know the saw or hostile
franchises look you know like they
should be in Nickelodeon or something so
they dug up these old tweets where he's
making you know jokes about raping
children and whatnot and and it's clear
there
so I mean you can say they're bad taste
or they're good taste they're funnier
they're not funny but it's not you know
it's it's not like Dennis Hastert's
private diary or anything right these
are jokes and he gets canned this is
politicizing I guess it's not free
speech but how do you deal with that
from your kind of defense attorney
perspective your interest in very robust
free speech and then we see stuff like
this going on all of the time the left
wingers did it to Brendan Eich the head
who had been named a few years ago the
head of mozilla firefox' a non-profit
that continues to build a browser that a
lot of people like he got canned after
somebody dug up evidence that he had
supported proposition 8 an anti-gay
marriage initiative here in california
sure is they are you know how do you
deal with these from a kind of
philosophical position is it getting
worse and is this is this what free
speech is all about so I I deal with it
a few ways first of all I think it's
always important even though people get
mad and say you don't need to tell me
that that's obvious to point out when
it's a First Amendment issue as opposed
to a cultural free speech issue okay
because it's very important to both that
we encourage education about what the
First Amendment is or isn't promote
knowledge of the extent of our free
speech rights as opposed to what you
might call our free speech values so I
think it's important to say yes a
company has a right to fire someone
a private company for a speech they
don't like and I think it's important
when a so on in a public job gets in
trouble for their speech that we
carefully go through the
well-established First Amendment
analysis of whether or not they can be
fired for that and do public employees
in general have broader free speech
rights they do workplace they do so
people who are public employees are kind
of a special case because their employer
wears both the government hat and the
employer hat and the way the analysis
winds up coming out is that their their
rights are not as robust as if they were
a citizen on the street and the
government was trying to
them for their speech but they're not as
you know illusory as the private
employee so the government basically
can't punish them for speech that's on
an issue of Public Interest unless it
can demonstrate that the balance of the
need for a workplace that's effective
and a government that operates outweighs
their free speech rights so I do First
Amendment cases on the path of public
employees who get retaliated against for
a legitimate political speech there's a
guy who I believe is a public
schoolteacher who then wrestles in a
kind of amateur pull you know
professional wrestling amateur league in
Pennsylvania who is like Baron von
blitzkrieg or something anywheres Nazi
paraphernalia and you know this type of
stuff and he I believe got bounced her
is about to get bounced because the
school is like yeah we you know that
doesn't seem to fit well with the idea
of educating little children about I
don't know you know like compulsory you
know couldn't pulser a gym classes or
something right it gets very confusing
very quickly because you know the one
thing about the Nazis is they really
believe in public education right but
yeah that's true
but what you know where where would
something like that come down in this
type of thing you should you know can
the can the school say you know what
this is going to cause so much
disruption even though you have the
right to do it get the [ __ ] out or do
they have to like methodically show this
is disruptive and that means three kids
a day whose parents are related to
soldiers or Holocaust survivors you know
who died in World War two or you know
had issues with the Nazis so get the
[ __ ] out or just lump it and live with
it
so it's a tough policy question but
there is a very specific
well-established First Amendment legal
route that you have to take and that
this is what I think people should know
about and apply so the first step is to
ask is this part of his job presumably
his job as a middle school teacher is
not wrestling and Nazi garb if it were
then they would be more able to fire him
they can fire you based on how you do
job okay yeah so if it's not part of his
job the next question is is an issue of
public interest that he's speaking or
acting on and so if this is his way of
self-expression out there the answer is
probably yes if for instance he went out
and badmouth the principal for having
bad breath or something probably that's
not an issue of Public Interest
I'm guessing if your persona is like
Baron von blitzkrieg and you're gonna
critique your for your principal it's
probably not about as bad breath
I'm thinking some kind of genetic or
cultural component religious maybe I
agree but if you were can if he were
criticizing some petty workplace issue
right that would not be protected
because it's not on an issue of Public
Interest right so then once you get past
that you get past this isn't someone
who's getting fired for how they did
their job we're talking about purely
internal matters then you get to the
hard part and that's the balancing
between the government's interest in a
stable workplace where everyone can get
along and where the government can
achieve its mission and the person's
First Amendment interests and the more
core the person's speech is to political
speech on issues of public concern the
more protected it's likely to be and the
more disruptive their speeches the more
unprotected it's likely to be so because
it could be that he's going out on the
weekends and he dresses up as Benjamin
Franklin and supports Bernie Sanders
Donald Trump and says like oh I'm
Benjamin Franklin and I I would love
Bernie Sanders or something like that
exactly so when we're talking about Nazi
stuff the way this is tended to play out
is that people who are in jobs where
there's a need for an appearance of
neutrality of even-handedness of equal
protection of their customers and the
people the government's interacting with
then the government is given fairly wide
fora t to fire people for engaging in
racist outside behavior the classic
example is cops if the cop is a Klansmen
on the weekend then the courts tend to
accept well the problem with a Klansman
cop is not only a worry he's gonna you
shoot non-white people even more so than
you know they already do but that
anytime we get sued for a shooting we're
completely screwed because you know our
cops of Klansmen in a school I can
imagine the police psychologist being
like you know what you you've gotta set
boundaries you need some time to
yourself if you're just coming from
being a cop to being a Klansmen right
you know take a break what is it about
you so in a school I suspect and courts
analysis is going to be similar so the
guy might say look the Nazism is ironic
it's mostly a dress-up fetish not a
political thing so he's gonna say you
know wrestling is traditional but
traditionally about you know pretending
to be these outsized characters and I
don't really reflect you but I think
he's gonna have trouble because people
are gonna say that education is about
all the kids no matter their ethnic
background being treated equal whereas
at a private school they might be like
Hayes doing it and sure why not you're
gone or you like either he's doing it
and we don't give a [ __ ] or you're gone
and that's the end of the issue so if
you're a private employee right then
absent your contract protecting you or
absent some state or local law
protecting you the First Amendment isn't
protecting you right okay so there are
some laws some states that limit the
ability to fire people for their
politics right and obviously you can't
fire someone from their politics when
that's just a ruse for firing them for
their gender or their race or something
like that generally but there were times
where if you were a member of the
Communist Party or or other parties you
could get fired that was one of the big
free speech fights of the 50s and 60s
but it sort of developed on a different
track than this the the the law on
speaking out as a government employee
developed on fairly mundane things you
know Pickering the key old case is a
teacher sending a letter to the editor
about how the district spends money
things badly another key cakes conic is
about a deputy da employee talking about
office management so these are not big
toes that tie into Harry Connick it is a
hairy conics father I believe who was
the da who was the employer in the case
yeah so iconic we got to get rid of this
guy he's nothing we don't know how many
anchor babies he's had but you know what
even once too much he's constitutionally
suspect Nick what about let's talk about
the you know the the case the moment and
by the time this interview was over much
less actually shows up online
we probably hopefully the aliens will
have invaded you know and Baron von
blitzkrieg will have won the big belt
but James Gunn getting canned sure over
this what what is your sense you know
any and again I mean there's the legal
questions and then there's kind of the
cultural questions and you talk about a
decision between first first amendment
law and then First Amendment kind of
values Colorado yeah how do those fit
together and is it do the laws tend to
be enforced in a more brittle harsh way
when we have a more brittle or narrow
First Amendment culture a free speech
culture or are these things totally
separate from one another well I think
people are more willing to support
robust application on the First
Amendment legally when there's a more
robust free speech culture but they do
operate separately and the trick with
First Amendment culture is I think that
people lose track of the idea that
everyone in the picture has First
Amendment rights
everyone has free speech rights so yeah
you look at it you look at the firing of
mr. gun done I think entirely cynically
by the people who accused him purely to
you know own the libs they say she's a
pure culture war move not out of gen any
genuine concern that he was actually a
pedophile at least not any non crazy
concern what you have to understand is I
think is that Disney as the employer has
First Amendment rights
to Disney has free association rights
and I'm not saying that makes it right
for them to fire them what I'm saying is
or wise but or wise but they do have the
right to fire they have the right and
what I'm saying is that we should bring
the free speech culture ideas
even-handedly so we shouldn't impose on
anyone any sort of obligation we're not
imposing on everybody so why not I think
that the reason why I shouldn't because
I just want to get rid of people I think
are douchebags well sure and then we
should judge you for being a judgmental
douchebag about that what else I can't
take it
what I'm saying is we shouldn't lionize
a person who tells douchey jokes on
Twitter and say that sacrosanct and you
should criticize it on the other hand be
very critical of someone's First
Amendment free association choices as
their employer okay I think you have to
be critical of everybody in the picture
so you know the weight off and this is
independent of the law stuff we can talk
a little bit but how do you get to that
like what what creates a flourishing
free speech you know a kind of volt
Aryan paradise of I you know and I
realized he didn't say it you know it's
probably a the same guy who wrote Chief
Seattle speech or something right in
1970 but you know the idea that I I'll
defend your right to say whatever you
want and you defend mine and we're
better off that way even if we agree on
nothing how do you get to that place
well I think you have to be very
cognizant of what it means to defend the
right first of all it means absolutely
you have to legally rigorously defend
the right and say that I hate this
speech but this is how the first amount
of applies and this is it their rights
I think the conflict we're getting into
politically in terms of free speech
culture is the not even handed way it
gets applied so when someone outrageous
and provocative whose whole schtick is
offending and owning the lib comes to
campus then I think they should be
allowed to I think the right to should
be protected I think that the right of
the students to invite them should be
legally protected I think that that
should be protected from physical
violence but there's also this sentiment
that
it should be protected from really
aggressive criticism or protest and you
know I don't see why we should lionize
someone who comes on campus to be a dick
and not equally lionized people who are
a dick in response that doesn't make
sense to me and I think this dichotomy
where because you're the guy on stage
you're married right
I don't want but you know you you you
spend a lot of time thinking about dicks
don't you well it's it's a consequence
of being a First Amendment lawyer it's
kind of an occupational health but you
know it's interesting with the campus
stuff it's like you know say you think
of somebody like Milo the best thing
yeah I mean the thing that extended his
15 minutes was he kept getting shut down
right because once he was allowed to
actually talk people were like god this
guy's just an [ __ ] like he has
nothing to say that is of interest to
anyone and he kind of starts to go away
exactly I think the the reaction to him
is often everything he wants it to be
it's it's empowering it's the most
important thing it's like you know this
guy's like God I don't have a speech
tonight it's a good thing I won't have
to give it so the the the free speech
values is a pitch to people about ethics
and morality and about what kind of
society we want and I think it's a very
unappealing pitch when what we're saying
is not only do you have to allow this
person to speak but you can't call them
an [ __ ] right okay that to me is
completely unappealing and I think that
that is the way that some of the
dialogue is drifting and some of the
reason that you get so much hostility to
talk about free speech about this happen
on the left or what is the basic dynamic
on the left that kind of corresponds
with this well on the left I guess it
would be that the idea that you
shouldn't be tone policing the idea that
you know not only should we listen to
people talking about these progressive
values but we shouldn't criticize the
way they utter them to me that's
nonsense I say we protect the right to
speak out freely we do that vigorously
and aggressively we make
use of the courts but you know you're
gonna call an [ __ ] an [ __ ] and
that's the way it goes and my right to
say that person is acting like a jerk is
no more or less important than the
person's right to be a jerk so I think
when we're trying to sell this package
that free speech values means we're
gonna sit here quietly while you're a
jerk on campus is not sensible and not
appealing the other thing I see going on
here that I think is a real problem is I
think that people are participating in
classifying free speech as a
conservative issue okay so part of this
is coming out of the sort of classically
conservative Supreme Court cases you
know that go against a union or go
against abortion or something like that
it makes it easy to classify the First
Amendment as being conservative if it
has conservative political outcomes but
the other thing that's happening and
then historically that's wrong because
I've seen in the 50s and 60s
conservatives weren't happy oh how you
know could be published with that
somebody being thrown in jail or oh
absolutely and agon papers could be
published saying that the First
Amendment is is conservative is
historically completely illiterate it's
about protecting mostly progressives
from being suppressed for most of the
twentieth century but the other thing
that's happening I think is that we're
buying into this this narrative where
you know the Liberals on campus want to
suppress speech and the Conservatives
want speech and therefore let's make fun
of the Liberals and let's lionize the
Conservatives you see a lot of sites you
know that instead of just talking about
the First Amendment our early culture
warrior sites where the free speech
fights are between liberalism and
conservatism you know first of all it's
not accurate free speech is in just as
much danger from conservatives you only
have to look at things like you know the
Attorney General of the United States
pretending to be against campus
censorship when he made an effort to
shut down speech about gays and lesbians
on campus you only have to look what was
what are the particulars of that oh he
he tried to use the force of law
to shut down gay and lesbian
organizations from presenting on campus
when he was a state attorney general
okay so you look at the increased
popularity in laws punishing students
for protests on campus now that's being
spawned as protecting people's right to
speech without interference but it's a
very vague ambiguous tool that can be
used to punish all types of speech you
look at these laws across the country
about how you can run over a protestor
if they scare you all this stuff are
examples of how conservative values can
also drive censorship so when we buy
into this narrative that free speech is
a conservative value and censorship its
liberal value we basically invite this
chasm where the First Amendment and free
speech values steadily gets less and
less support because I mean the pendulum
will swing again everyone thinks that oh
this is the worst ever and this is the
way it's gonna be forever but you know
you only have to look back to you know
Obama getting elected and all of a
sudden and we're we're in a democratic
blue country forever and then look a few
years before that and the Republicans
have a permanent majority it swings back
and forth and so if you classify you
participate in classifying free speeches
the conservative value you are screwed
when the pendulum swings back to
liberalism again and it may start to
have very dramatic impact long-term on
the judiciary on politicians on
everybody who's going to accept this
frame and start using that idea it's an
excuse to restrict speech more and sell
it to people you know that it's okay to
have this type of censorship because
those guys are talking about the First
Amendment but you know that's just a
conservative trope so I think that even
conservatives should be very reluctant
to accept that what about you know one
of the things in the past few months
we've had the Facebook hearings where
Mark Zuckerberg talked before various
parts of Congress and you know I
probably the single biggest takeaway was
that many people in Congress had never
heard of
book or did not even know that there
were computers I mean I think they think
centipede games in like old restaurants
that's the Internet or something it's a
series of tubes yeah you know but does
Facebook or how much does it worry you
when you see a place like Facebook
Twitter has done this to a certain
degree YouTube has done this or surgery
Google where they recognize and they
kind of openly say is Facebook as
eckleburg did yeah you know it's time
we're gonna be regulated it's time for
regulation and I want to help you write
those regulations and at one point even
said I want to help you write those
regulations that I should because I know
this business better than you guys do
and you know that these regulations are
going to make it harder for the next
Facebook or the next public media social
media platform to come out again this
isn't strictly legal Facebook is a
private entity they can do whatever the
hell they want at blah blah blah but is
this worrying kind of in terms of not
not in terms of the legality of First
Amendment stuff or possibly of in the
culture but this is kind of like the
infrastructure that the the technology
of free expression is starting to move
into a different space are you worried
about that and how do we make sure you
know I guess to wrap it up the question
is like how do I make sure that a
diamond and silk get fully you know get
get the audience they deserve because
this is that ridiculous terrible duo
that is pro-trump right it's constantly
saying and Ted Cruz would be like you
know diamond of silk aren't as big as
they should be because Facebook and
Twitter and YouTube and you know
everyone in the world you know is is
keeping them down through their
algorithms you know but you know what to
put a pin on it it's you know the
Conservatives are constantly talking
about how like all forms of social media
have now conspired I mean it's like a
line drift graphed it out of the
Communist Manifesto all the powers of
the world are now aligned on social
media to make sure diamond and silk
doesn't get the full universal audience
it deserves well exactly I mean you hear
this rhetoric coming from conservatives
that sounds very much like what you used
to get from very liberal people the
market is broken these private companies
are making unfair decisions we've got to
regulate
that's not conservative to me diamond
and soaps should get the full audience
they can get they have a right to that
they don't have the right to the private
platform other choice because again to
come back to what I said earlier I don't
think people appreciate or agree that
Twitter and Facebook have rights to free
speech and free association rights and
to go all Mitt Romney on you
corporations are people to my mind
corporations are just the way that
groups of people admit that some of my
very best friends are corporations well
I'm like they're you know I don't know
when I called uber and I need a ride
right that corporation shows up half the
time my friends are like a [ __ ] them
I'm asleep but so my concern is it's
similar to what I said earlier about
having to put the same standard on
everybody okay I think that Twitter and
Facebook have free association free
speech rights to say this is the type of
platform we want to have you know
Disneyland they can decide to have the
type of environment they want to have a
frame family-friendly one okay Twitter
and Facebook can decide they want to be
the sort of places where you can speak
and Nazis won't get in your face you
know we want Dimond but not silk silk is
that that's the deal so it's appalling
to me when people see private companies
making free expression choices and using
that as an excuse okay let's regulate
this industry because whatever the
government's gonna do it's going to
screw it up it's gonna do it terribly
and it's going it's not going to
increase speech so I find that sort of
throw the baby out with the bathwater
idea that these private applications of
speech are not helping me so I want to
limit that speech to be very
short-sighted because if people think
that Facebook and Twitter are judgmental
about politics wait till the government
gets involved there's there's no logical
or rational reason to think that they
will do better you know when we talk
about free speech on Twitter and Twitter
is obviously like the single greatest
way to get rid of your enemies right you
know Roseanne stepped in it I mean she
kind of threw it out there but James
Gunn and other people what are some of
you
favorite Twitter insults you you are a
master you're like the end of the way
Bob Dylan is the master of the put down
song positively forestry ditty of wind
you know a variety of songs like that
you're a pretty good put down artists on
Twitter what are some of your favorite
put downs you know my father are so
proud and my mother would be too
I don't know I love the language I love
English and I love its possibilities so
you know to me it's a fun to do a
combination of the obscene and the non
obscene
so you know if you call someone a scruff
less [ __ ] nugget then they probably
haven't heard that that week you know
they probably heard all sorts of other
things that week but none at that
particular I loved the idea you're like
the Frederic Bastiat of Twitter the
famous ninth the French journalist who
was the it was famous for the phrase
what is seen and what is unseen but you
are what is seen and what is obscene
well you know I get a certain amount of
static from some people and I have to
explain to them that you know Twitter is
its own medium and that no one thinks
that you know someone who calls someone
a you know Demi literate [ __ ] waffle on
Twitter that doesn't mean they're
necessarily the sort of person who's
gonna say that in court or at you know a
garden party have you have you had like
open-heart surgery yet where you're like
oh yeah can don't worry I'm the best
[ __ ] waffle in this business just as the
the anesthesia mask is going on your
head I have had opposing parties
including recently a DA in court attempt
to quote me on Twitter to embarrass or
contradict me it's never it's never gone
in their favor but is that a legitimate
tactic because that's essentially what
is happening more and more we're you
know say again James Gunn the the
director who's made billions of dollars
for Disney right you know in movie
theaters he's not making money for
Disney on Twitter for God's sake no but
he is but he gets somebody you know
rifles through his back catalogue gets a
bunch of tweets is it legitimate to you
know kind of leverage what somebody's
saying on Twitter or Facebook or
whatever
and throw it into a different setting to
[ __ ] them over I don't know what you
mean by legitimate its speech - speech I
think very often ya know and what I mean
I guess I don't want to use like a
British term like is it cricket
obviously it's legal obviously you can
do it is that a is it a strategy that we
should kind of enjoy and do more of
where you bring in you know you bring in
a semi irrelevant information from one
sphere of activity in a person's life to
kind of discredit them no I don't like
it as a tactic I think that it usually
backfires in court from what I know
Observatory which is good and the people
who try to do it or generally kind of
ham-fisted about it and I think that
using it you know in the culture wars to
get people fired is very much a
double-edged sword and no one should be
feeling confident about that happening
anyone you you know you live by the
sword die by the sword and you know
anyone's vulnerable to that sort of
thing unless you're gonna be boring what
about something though that is you know
I think everybody would agree is more
serious let's say somebody is a horrible
racist misogynistic homophobe something
over here and then that gets brought to
bear in their professional setting you
know is that you know should should
those rivers or those streams never
cross you know that's a free speech and
free association in Washington so the
people who are bringing their conduct
into the dialogues place else are
engaging in their own speech the people
who are making free association
decisions based on it are engaging in
their own speech and I think the trick
is to judge all of them not just one of
them so you don't just say you're always
pushing for that kind of let's be
serious about this and as this is an
ecosystem but let's if and I don't know
that you can do this but like you you
get rid of the criminal charges against
Harvey Weinstein right but then if he's
still making really good movies and this
is also we're already in a
counterfactual because he had been
bombing at the box office for a long
time right
is not you know it's not an accident
that he he got can
after 15 years of stinking at you know
making money making movies but is his
personal life and his professional life
you know should those be held separately
Jim Jordan as a politician I'd you know
hire congressman who was an assistant
wrestling coach at Ohio State is now
being charged with knowingly looking the
other way when something like 150
wrestling students say they were being
molested by the team doctor and that
Jordan had to have known about it that
happened a long time ago he wasn't a
congressman should that affect you know
whether or not he gets to be the next
Speaker of the House that's like saying
should I like poetry it's a it's a
matter of you I just want to point out
you just compared child molesting to
poetry not good poetry but so no what I
I mean because this is one of the I
guess but yeah outcomes and it's not
really a legal thing but it's like if
everything everybody's been doing for
the past 15 or 20 years is recorded
somewhere right because we've all been
writing and we've all been tweeting or
we have pictures on Facebook this is
like that Robert Mitchum movie out of
the past that was made into against all
odds like everybody has the James Woods
character or you know Kirk Douglas
showing up right so he's gonna [ __ ] up
your present so but you're asking really
how should we treat art based on what we
think of the artists personal life or
the artist as a personality what I'm
saying is that's a very personal
decision you know I love vogner even
though he's a terrible racist and
everything I love vogner except for the
music no and you know Ezra Pound is a
big anti-semite and a terrible poet he
was a good editor that's it right now so
to me it's idiosyncratic and I'm not
going to pretend that it's rational or
methodical some people I no longer enjoy
their art because they're total [ __ ]
on their personal line or some people I
do
I don't know and and I suppose in
different cases I mean depending on the
severity of the bad behavior if people
apologize if people make amends right if
they show they've changed or it does
interfere here what drives me crazy here
is how I think completely hypocritical
almost everyone is about this so almost
everyone doesn't like it when it happens
to some people and do like it what
happens to others so everyone who's
saying that it's terrible this is
happening you know they're likely to
applauded it when it's you know Roman
Polanski whose movies I can't watch
because I think of him being you know
unrepentant fled child rapist you know
there's an easy way out of that too is
just don't watch this movies because 90%
of them are terrible well exactly and
but I think those people will go one way
or the other depending on how they feel
about the artist what we're really
talking about even in politics to some
extent my comparison isn't so much child
molestation to poetry but it's politics
to art there's no more scandal it was
kind of clarifying the Republican
nominee for senator from Alabama who was
you know credibly charged with basically
being a jailbait junkie I mean like it
was cruising malls and stuff like that
didn't have good he even Ted Cruz
eventually withdrew his his support for
him and things like that right he was
just concerned about education yeah
that's you got to start young yeah
exactly but but it is do you feel like
we're just getting worse and worse
because of tribal politics instead of
using this as a moment to reset a
conversation where we can say look
people are human a lot of situations are
very uncomfortable very difficult we
need to be more human and be more kind
rather than it be more tribal and just
celebrate this that or the other thing
I'm always skeptical with the idea that
things are really worse now than they
have been on almost anything so I would
ask you when would you find a time in
America when some element of personality
didn't wind up in politics you know
whether it's a you know someone has a
history of depression or right now musky
with its melting snowflakes
yeah rying or you know the horrible
thing is that the founding father said
no and the founder I mean we have not
even tapped into how mean
wonderfully nasty they were at the time
absolutely I mean Hamilton is basically
musical indistinguishable from Mean
Girls yes I'd love what I like about it
too is that Hamilton the guy from New
Jersey wins that's right you know so
it's but does the you know somebody like
Thomas Eagleton who was who was George
McGovern's first running mate when it
came out that he had he had had shock
treatment and it had been treated for
depression it was like I could get out
right probably wouldn't happen now that
part wouldn't but it's an illustration
of how all the time we've you know used
all sorts of personality and background
we just choose different ones now so
before it was any tinge that you had
some sort of connection to you know
communism or sympathy or you were
insufficiently hostile to communism
right was the deal-breaker
now it's racism and you know I'm not
sure that I think that's a terrible yeah
thing I think it can be overused and
used unfairly and uncharitably but what
I'm saying is I'm skeptical of this view
that now we are more than ever
trading and personalities rather than
politics you I've heard you describe
yourself as a civil libertarian which is
a code to me that you're really a
communist or something how do you how do
you define your politics generally or
your ideology so I'm a civil libertarian
meaning that I'm in favor a very
vigorous protection and application of
constitutional rights to protect
individuals I would say I'm a small L
libertarian that means that you know I'm
not going to be marching to privatise
the air force tomorrow but I believe in
a sense of Bill you do look forward to
the day when they have to hold bake
sales in order to buy bombers or
something like yeah and I'll be there
believe me I I will I will eat up my way
to a stealth bomber right on my ass III
describe small-l libertarianism as a
sensibility where you are skeptical
about whether the government is the
right tool to do something skeptical
about whether the government winds up
getting you the result
you want skeptical about whether the use
of government authority to achieve ends
winds up really benefiting rich powerful
people because that's the way government
works so I'm not so result-oriented
I don't freak out I'm not one of the
people saying we should blow up the UN
I'm not going to strip on stage at a
convention but well there goes our gala
fiftieth anniversary we're gonna have to
get a new headlining act thank you but
my my philosophy is always asked why
should the government be doing this does
it really help for the government where
did that come from it came from concerns
about free speech and the rights of
defendants it came you had been a
federal prosecutor yes right I mean the
worst of the worst the types of people
who suppress and gag the speech of media
organizations like reason and then you
get on the other side well I started to
go on the other side when I was a
prosecutor I started to become
disenchanted were you throwing cases you
were like Al Pacino and then justice for
all where you're like off you know
you're out of order judge no but I
started to think you know is this what I
want to do with my life I still respect
the people there it's some of the best
years of my career it's a wonderful
community of people but I you know I I
can't participate in the drug war and I
just think that I'm much more true
believer as a defense lawyer than I ever
was as a prosecutor and I guess my sense
is that I understand the need for
government I'm not you know I'm not the
stereotypical libertarian that people
derived as someone who wants us to be
Somalia right but I think that we always
have to be very cautious that government
is the you know the giant vicious dog
you bring into your house to protect you
from robbers well you've got to be
careful around the dog and the baby and
the cat and that type of thing okay yeah
government traditionally winds up
protecting the interests of the
connected the moneyed and the powerful
and you know if you had to point to
something that kind of displays recently
my libertarian sensibility and what gets
me annoyed it's the story
this week about San Francisco talking
about banning cafeterias in businesses
like Google or Twitter Facebook because
if you've got an internal cafeteria then
people won't go patronize and local
restaurants and it's the Restaurant
Association that's pushing that so you
know it's nominally something that they
have some thin veneer that it's a good
of society but it's really one group of
people with money going after another
people group of people with money so my
sensibility is not so much always
exactly what the outcome should be the
but that we should look at things like
that the decision to use government as
the tool to achieve something with great
skepticism in one way you were talking
about the first amendment we tend to
take it as a given going back to the
ancient Egyptians or whoever settled
this country that we always had First
Amendment rights and they were
vigorously enforced but really when you
start to go back it's it's the 50s
kind of late 50s and the 60s a good
chunk of time in the 70s these what we
consider First Amendment rights are so
recently one the robust First Amendment
where you can you can shout maybe not
fire and a credit to you but you can
share [ __ ] you had you know and we have
technological innovation so that you can
say whatever you want wherever you want
in ways that were unforeseeable even
twenty years ago are we doing enough to
remind both people our age is generally
but also younger people that this is
kind of like a bubble we're living in a
historical bubble that could pop at any
time does that inability to kind of look
at and look backward or to look forward
disturb you and then what it what's the
best way to address that so I does
disturb me because I think people don't
know as much about the First Amendment
as they should of course I'm a lawyer I
think that people should be familiar
with it it's the way mechanic thinks you
should be able to you know know how your
car works but I mean the First Amendment
is what lets me say that lets you
disagree with me
and it's not rocket science I mean I can
do it I'm not the brightest guy around
and I think people could understand the
background a lot more and I think people
could get behind the stories the First
Amendment is about incredible stories of
Americans standing up for the
selves and fighting back against
incredible odds that we can barely
imagine standing up in those
circumstances so I've been doing a
podcast called make no law that's about
the history of the First Amendment one
case at a time and I've gotten to talk
to people like Mary Beth tinker though
who was a 13 year old girl who put on a
black armband to protest the Vietnam War
against you know all sorts of social
ostracism and outrage you know about a
guy named Sidney Street burned an
American flag because he was outraged
the james Meredith had gotten shot
during a March all these stories about
the First Amendment are important not
just because they show how recent these
rights are and how often they've been
trampled but they show how Universal
some of the issues are and how broad the
group is that spot for these rights the
stories of the way I think we fight
against this narrative that free speech
is just a conservative value you know
Mary Beth tinker wasn't a conservative
Sidney Streep wasn't a conservative a
lot of these people were progressives or
were outcasts where the the despised
peacemaker was what like in Chavez
witness or some day Adventist I think
they were Methodists it was a very
progressive family the the parents were
very anti-war but she decided on her own
I was nice I was just telling some
people I worked with I think last night
that they came through was either them
or somebody and their family came to the
middle school and kind of talked about
it and what was really interesting about
their experience was that in the context
of the Gulf War or you know the wars
were fighting now people were kind of
like you're you're really part of the
problem you're the reason we lost
Vietnam or something right and so it's
it's you know it's a living breathing
history case and a lot of this stuff but
it's it's terrifying where you know from
a literary point of view and and a mix
because I think these books are
generally unreadable and best forgotten
but even books like Ulysses and Lady
Chatterley's Lover
sure could only be published legally in
the US and like 1960 or 61 and it's like
what kind of what kind of free speech
country are we pretending to be when it
takes that long to
published books that are just not good
not even going to be read by most people
and people when they learn the history
behind some of the censorship tropes
that we use every day tend to be
appalled that tend to be convert so you
know everyone uses the fire in a crowded
theater right shall fire in a crowd and
theater and cause a panic when you tell
people about this case that it's
actually about someone protesting
against the draft and war won in very
patriotic pro rights terms and they got
jailed for it
then all of a sudden they're not so
thrilled about that rhetoric anymore or
you know people talk non-stop about how
we should be able to stop hate speech
because it's fighting words well if
people look at the history of that case
and see okay this is a guy who was not
uttering fighting words he was a
Jehovah's Witness preaching on a street
corner and a mob was attacking him and
the cops were basically okay I'm gonna
go have your fun and they only arrested
him when he talked back to a cop all of
a sudden that urge to use that classic
exception as long or so strong so I
think the the way to win hearts and
minds on this is not to classify free
speech as conservative or liberal it's
not to use it as sort of a culture war
weapon on the lips should we start
especially in trumps America maybe we
should start adding it as a good Russian
value absolutely dah dah
final question do you think Kavanagh
will be nominate or will be confirmed
and what is the general role of the
Supreme Court in changing American
society is it is it a radical game
changer does it is it a lagging
indicator it does it certified social
trends that have already are
transformations that have taken place
does it speed it up a little bit you
know so Kavanaugh yes or now is he going
to get in and if you have any specific
gossip that would keep him from getting
in some tweets about pedophiles or three
men and a baby
please out them right now but then how
important is the Supreme Court well I
don't see how he doesn't get in I mean I
I hear all these scenarios about how
people might oppose him and of course
you know you got the
the Rand Paul's of the were all
posturing that they're still making up
their mind but I think it's pretty clear
he gets in the Supreme Court is hugely
important over the last century and I
don't know whether you say that the
trends drive the court or the court
drives the trends but you look at things
like desegregation abortion gay marriage
free speech all these rights that really
the court has been the driving force on
it's hugely important and yet perversely
it's the institution that I think we are
as a society the least well informed
about about how does its work about how
it gets to those ends and that's why
it's so easy to manipulate people to say
that this was a purely political
decision or you know to say that law and
order as a judicial value as opposed to
a conservative political value or that
you know free speech is conservative as
opposed to a legal doctrine so I think
what we need to make the Supreme Court a
more fair a more an institution that we
can respect more that is seen as less
autocratic is to have more people
understand how it gets to where it gets
understand what goes on there and again
it's not rocket science
ken and I said I was gonna ask you one
last question but let me throw this out
there to the Supreme Court you know is
more diverse ethnically religiously
gender wise etc than it ever has been or
you know basically as long as Harvard
and Yale or religion yes yeah this is
what I was going to ask is is there a
problem with it becoming concentrated
where I believe it is all two schools I
mean it's just two schools you know are
represented therefore in terms of law
degrees the people increasingly of
freaking Neil Gorsuch and Brett
Kavanaugh went to high school together
right
you know everybody goes to the same law
school everybody you know is that a
problem most of them are from the same
part of the country geographically is
there is there a stronger case for a not
just ideological diversity on the
Supreme Court but a geographical one and
you know educational what a Paget
pedagogical one I think the bigger
impact may be the sort of classic paths
of
idea the idea that you go to a big
clerkship and then maybe you teach or
maybe you work as a Solicitor General
and eventually you're on the federal
bench it's a fairly narrow range I like
to see the diversity of legal experience
because I think that people who have
only been professors or judges and have
never been in the proverbial trenches
whether it's a prosecutor or a defense
attorney or a trial it do we need a bail
bondsman on the Supreme Court well as
much as I'm against bail bonds well you
know for a year at a time I am with a
premium to be repaid I would like to see
more people and there are a few of them
who have real experience trying cases
dealing with clients because one of the
problems at the Supreme Court I think is
the very sort of elite academic air that
can be very removed from what legal
practices really like and it can be a
real problem when people on the court
have ideas about the way things happen
and in the trial court and those ideas
aren't really connected to reality so
you know Scalia's police professionalism
thing that we talked about is kind of an
example of that but it's also the court
has to make a lot of decisions that are
kind of cloaked in law but are really
about what's reasonable
what if he's figure I saw an episode of
TJ Hooker right now they would never do
that
so yeah this guy's guilty I saw the one
you know where the entire plot was about
a guy with a laser sight on his gun and
they defeated him with a disco ball
that's why I miss these but the move
away from TJ hoes we're back to the
Supreme Court I think that they're
making a lot of decisions about what
trial lawyers should do or should be
able to do what trial judges should do
and I think sometimes those decisions
are not informed by actual experience in
the trial court so I would like to see
more Supreme Court justices who have
been a public defender or a DA or a
trial lawyer or representative defendant
or defendant well I mean a defendant
before you know
before their term in the Supreme Court
and I mean that seems almost inevitable
- for you so I think that people who
have been there and done the work that
they're ruling on would inevitably cause
a change in the makeup of the court and
it wouldn't be something as you know
like geography it would be about
experience well we'll leave it there
we've been talking with Ken white he is
a partner at brown white and Osborne a
defense attorney firm in California
he's also the host of a podcast that is
called make no law which is about the
First Amendment and of course he blogs
at Pope at one of the most exciting and
foul language ridden blogs in the legal
world but also anywhere else
ken thanks for talking it's been a great
pleasure for reason i'm nicholas me
[Music]